venus de marseille et de ses alentours
ils sont plusieurs centaines à défiler
dans les rues de la capitale phocéenne
ce mardi matin les professionnels des
services de réanimation infirmiers aides
soignants réclame une formation
spécifique diplômante en règle générale
nous en tout cas au ch de toulon on a la
chance d'être d'être doublé huit
semaines pour les infirmiers et deux
semaines pour les aides soignants mais
au-delà de ça pour acquérir les
compétences suffisantes et pour se
sentir à l'aise nous sommes son travail
et en toute sécurité
il faut un an actuellement aucune
formation n'est dispensé dans leur école
tous apprennent le métier sur le tas en
doublon avec d'autres praticiens plus
expérimentés je peux pas dire grâce
parce que c'est pas le mot mais à cause
de cette crise qu on a vraiment mis le
doigt sur sur la spécificité parce que
il a fallu augmenter le nombre de lits
rapidement en un temps record et du coup
augmenter le personnel donc d'aidés
soignants pour la plupart volontaires
sont venus nous prêter main forte
mais ces gens là n'étaient pas du tout
capable de prendre en charge des malades
de réanimation en défaillance
multiviscérale donc c'est là où on s'est
rendu compte qu'effectivement c'était
compliqué et c est la réa ça s'invente
pas ces professionnels demandent
également des moyens délits du personnel
mais aussi une revalorisation salariale
alors moi je parle pour moi ça fait dix
ans que je suis infirmière en
réanimation
avant la crise du coc vide j'étais à
1880 euros
nex aujourd'hui j'ai tellement fait de
j'ai doublé montant de travaillant avec
les heures supplémentaires avec tout ça
donc mon salaire est pas représentatif
de ce que je dois gagner de base parce
que mais j'ai travaillé j'ai plus gagné
effectivement parce que j'ai fait des
énormément d'heures supplémentaires mais
ce qui veut dire moins de repos et voilà
c'est vêtus de leurs blouses de travail
qu'ils ont défilé dans les rues de
marseille pancartes à la main
épuisé après une année faso covic 19
mais loin d'être abattu